you know people who say how do you
balance your life and your work i know
that they hate one of those two parts in
their own life there is no work-life
balance 1983 we started the
international dermal institute which is
still the number one training program in
the industry and we launched dermalogica
in january of 1986. and that business
generates hundreds of millions of
dollars a year we knew that the big
opportunity was going to be a product
lots of people have great ideas every
day the difference most people can't
execute because the details are really
important and most people miss them will
start to think they're petty
a brand triggers emotional responses i'm
not a diva but i am strong and i know
what makes a business successful we
can't be afraid that some people won't
like what we say we have to say it
we both know that we could just spend
all of our time just doing business
what's the cost of that i would
self-sabotage relationships we were just
working so hard and lucy came downstairs
and she said mum i just and i said lucy
for gonna say what is wrong
and she said i wanted to give you a hug
you look so cross
i was just stood there with my child in
front of me looking scared of me
[Music]
that was the tipping point for me i had
to ask for help
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
direva ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
as i delve deep into your story into
your book it became so apparently clear
to me that
your early years your childhood were
very very formative can you tell me
about those early years and how they
shaped and molded you into the person
you were to become today i think at the
time obviously i didn't realize exactly
how formative my childhood was going to
be i think
most of us look back at our childhood
feel better or worse and realize that's
actually where so much of whatever i am
as an adult came from
so i was born in edinburgh scotland um
the youngest of four girls
my mum and dad um had been
they met in the second world war in
india dad was a little older than my mum
my mum was 38 my dad was 50
when he died of heart attack suddenly
not expected did not know he was ill
my mother
at 38 with four children
had not worked since she married and the
reason was she was a trained nurse
but at that time in the uk and it
carried on until i think the early 70s
and it did here too if you were a
married woman you gave up your job to a
single woman because it was assumed that
you didn't need the work that was true
in nursing and in teaching so she hadn't
worked since 1945.
she also didn't know how to drive a car
and she had no financial literacy
but this
woman my mother
she pulled herself together
she got work as a nurse she had a friend
who was then working at the western
general hospital in edinburgh she called
her up she said pat i need a job
she said
what can you give me and she said i can
give you a night shift seven to seven
because
i was two so i wasn't going to school my
mom had to take care of me during the
day and then go to work
and so everything was kind of determined
right there my mother
drummed into every one of us
learn how to do something
because if you don't know how to do
something literally a skill set in your
hands that you can
turn on a penny and go into work right
away
i don't she didn't know what she would
have done without her training and so
that became
absolutely concrete in my head i have to
be able to
support myself i have to be able to earn
my own money
and i can't ever put my
future in the hands of of someone else's
um income or success and
so yes that was highly formative it then
led me to the life i i know i've led and
also what things i care about what i
think is important
and you the loss of your father at two
and three quarters years old what impact
in hindsight did that have on
you directly
i think it was huge
one thing the the emotion i remember
feeling at the time
was not grief exactly because i wasn't
quite sure what had happened to him they
didn't say to me right away
he's dead that i was told he'd gone away
and then my sister judy who's next one
up from me she's six years older than me
told me directly he's not coming back
he's dead
and i
at that stage i was about five four and
a half five i was going to school
and the next emotion i felt was was
shame
that i didn't have
a father i didn't know anyone else that
didn't have a father i didn't know you
could grow up in a family without father
so i hid it
and as far as relationship and role
modelling i didn't realize then
but i do now
here i am i grew up in a household of
very strong capable women that's how i
saw them they were all older than me
bigger than me they helped me get
dressed helped me they did everything
i then went to an all-girls school
and i was i had all women teachers i was
a brownie and a girl guide
and so i'd never had that relationship
role played for me i'd never really
thought about there being not that i of
course i knew there was a difference but
i hadn't really thought about the power
dynamic i hadn't seen that actually
and then i i went to a friend's house
when i was 11 her dad came home we were
home about 4 30 and her dad came home at
about six i think and sat down right
away and
her mum gave him a cup of tea and he put
on the tv and
i i thought he was sick i said is your
dad not well and she said no he's fine
and i said oh
well oh because the only time i'd ever
been given a cup of tea sitting in a
chair was when i was sick and my mom
would say well get up and you know get
dressed put on your dressing gown
and now in later life
i realize it's impacted me a great deal
it it as i've been married now to
raymond
for well over 30 years we got married in
1990.
so what's that no
longer right
how long have i been married forever
and i think that a lot in my
relationship with raymond um i thought i
was always being very independent and
doing the right thing by doing
everything i could but i also realized
that was exclusionary i i can be very
exclusionary of the other person hard to
ask for help
not because i consciously don't want to
but because emotionally i don't feel i
need to that's not great so there's a
lot to unpack and work through that
formative like really pivotal advice
that your mum gave you which was learn
how to do something it seemed so simple
but it was so clearly really profound
for you and has been throughout your
life at that age what is it that you
wanted to learn how to do what is it you
wanted to be when you grew up when
you're you know 11 11 years old so
actually i remember looking in the
bournemouth evening echo newspaper and
saying to my mum look this hair salon is
hiring 15 year old apprentices and i
think i was about 11 and i said i'm
going to cut it out and keep it because
when i'm 16
and i leave school i will apply
and and my mom said well i think you'll
stay at school longer and i think you'll
go to university
which no one in my family had
and i thought well maybe
but that was in my head i i
i wanted to to i got my first saturday
job at 13 working in a salon
and i saw
first-hand proof that if you know how to
do that you know how to earn money
and then when that salon hired a skin
therapist then called a beauty therapist
but i don't like the word beauty when
applied to people's appearance
um
i realized that that's actually what i
want to do i want to be a skin therapist
so it's pretty pretty early
you don't end up going to university
at that stage you went to university
primarily if you were going to follow a
profession
legal the law or be a doctor or an
academic
or a pharmacist or i couldn't quite
grasp
the immediacy of how that was going to
equip me to be
self-determined
quickly
you see my biggest fear growing up
after my father had passed away was that
my mum would
i used to make these elaborate plans of
what would happen if my mum died and
then how old was i would i be taken into
foster care or would i would my older
sister be able to be my guardian and at
that stage my older sister was 15 when
my dad died but when my older sister
turned 21 and i was eight
i was so relieved because i knew
now
she's an adult and married she would be
able to i go and live with her so i'd
make all these plans of what would
happen
and i wanted to be self-determined
quickly and and so when i was looking at
a long haul of three years education
maybe i just couldn't attach myself to
it i wanted to be able to do a training
that i could travel with i could work
with it would be literally in my hands
and now i realize in my head and in my
heart and it could take me anywhere i
wanted to
that sounds like a consequence of the
the advice your mother had instilled in
you that learned how to do something and
she really had tried to make you sort of
autonomous and self-determined for
many reasons yeah so 19 years old you
yeah you look at the newspaper yeah i
look at the newspaper
and it's a sunday and it's freezing cold
uh in england it's it's
winter in 1977.
and
um freezing and i had a gas meter so you
had to put coins in to get the heating
on and i never hadn't you know i was
working as a as a disqualified so i was
but i was still working as a junior in a
salon so i never had enough money
and um
i had a boyfriend who said with me who
said jesus bloody freezing and what's
the hottest place on earth today i just
want to know where it is so i looked at
the weather in the sunday paper
and i said it's johannesburg and it was
then it was before we went into you know
celsius um i said it's 106.
which was really hot and he said god i
wish i was in janisberg and i said me
too
where's that he said south africa
geography wasn't super strong for me
turned over the page
and as i turned the page there was a
quarter page ad
taken by the south african government
for assisted passage
if you would emigrate
to south africa and i think australia
and canada used to do the same thing as
well in the uk
then the government of south africa
would pay your passage they would assist
it it would cost you 40 pounds
to go
which was really it was a lot of money
but it wasn't
that much money that we couldn't have
scraped it together
and just on a whim it was a sunday the
next day salons were closed it was a
monday that's pretty typical still in
salons
we called the number in london and
got the papers because there was no
internet you couldn't google anything or
look anything up filled them out and
emigrated to
south africa with what intention getting
a job
i was pretty good at what i did and i
knew i could get a job i'll just get a
job in a salon and i'll start working
and for assisted passage you had to
fulfill one of the requirements one of
the jobs that they needed to hire for
and there were ten listed and the number
one was patissera well i wasn't a
participant a pastry maker number two
was a butcher
definitely i wasn't a butcher number
three was a hairdresser
bingo for my boyfriend and number four
was then as the name was beauty
therapist and that was me
wow and how did that phase of your life
go so from between 19 and 22 roughly
yeah when you're in south africa how
when you reflect on that how was that
experience
well it was hugely formative
first of all um we got the boyfriend and
i tony and i got married it was easier
to apply for assisted passage if you
were a couple
and you would get housing
now i was also crazy about him and and
he was about me and off we went
19 years old he got married yes wow
not a not a successful marriage we
didn't know each other very well great
boyfriend wrong husband
and so that lasted about a year when i
was in south africa
and yet
there i am now on the other side of the
planet with no family no cell phones no
computer no face time there was nothing
like that in order to call her home i
had to go to the post office in cape
town and book an international call and
it was expensive so i literally called
home
once a year
but i can work which is great because i
can support myself
my marriage is broken up and i've got to
wait to get a divorce because there's no
such thing as a sudden divorce in south
africa it's then operating under dutch
reform church law
so i had to be separated for two years
and then they give you a decree and
eyesight and then i could apply for one
more year i had to be
separated never go not going back
together again and only then do you get
your decree absolutely so it was three
years before i could get divorced
i read that you walked out one day
essentially from the marriage and he'd
emptied your personal bank account and
yeah you were pretty much stood on your
track suit on the street on your own
yeah was in the street
my clothing had been thrown out of an
upstairs window of our rented terraced
house
along with some garbage bags trash bags
rubbish bags
and i picked up the stuff that wasn't
cut up because he cut up a lot of my
stuff as he threw it out stuffed it in
the trash bag
got in my car and i drove to a friend's
house and as i drove away i can i feel
it now i can feel myself sitting in the
car it was a mazda and i was driving
away and i looked in the rearview mirror
and i could hardly see because i was
crying i was really scared and
emotionally very devastated and i was
shaking
and i looked in the rearview mirror and
i just promised myself
this will never happen again i will
never allow myself to be this vulnerable
i will never allow myself to ever be in
a situation that i
run away
with my clothes in trash bags
i'm going to
pull my act together in a big way
that was a lot that happened in that
four years that was probably the most
formative time of my life
what seemed like the greatest
calamity because remember now my mother
had been widowed but i'd now just walked
out of a marriage
and at that age
i guess i thought it was that was my
marriage not like oh i'll have more
i've just walked out of my marriage
i am now alone
the very thing that happened to my
mother i didn't have kids but
i think all of that was wrapped up and
you know i probably should have had a
lot of therapy a lot sooner but i didn't
so all of that was wrapped up i felt
incredibly vulnerable physically
vulnerable
so
i hit the ground running and i'd now got
a job working for a company for a
skincare company selling to salons it
was redken which now owned by l'oreal
but then they were privately owned by an
entrepreneur paula kent meehan in los
angeles
and she started redking with her
hairdresser jerry reading that's where
the name red ken came from
jerry reading and paula kent
and so i had a company car i worked
really hard i was determined to do well
get promoted which i did
and within a year i had been made the
brand manager for the skincare division
and transferred to johannesburg
and johannesburg was where i met
raymond
and so how does that then lead you from
johannesburg to los angeles that was
raymond werwind we worked together for
the next year
he was my boss's boss so i didn't report
directly to him but i would be in
meetings with him because i was the
brand manager for the skincare division
and he was brilliant he is brilliant and
i love and respect and admire that
we would have conversations at the at
the table at work and
everyone would be positing some idea or
another
and he would see right through
everything to the conclusion he's very
pragmatic okay i've heard everything
this is this is what i'm thinking this
is what we should do and he was right
and i saw that and i loved that and i
felt very inspired by that
and he saw in me my creativity because i
would usually be the one at that table
that was saying i know we're out of
stock of that color of foundation
because we haven't had a shipment from
los angeles but i think that was in our
gift sets last christmas can we see how
many we've got left over in the
warehouse break open the palettes
because it's now march
and just take out the foundation and
sell that and that actually was true
story that's what we did so he loved my
creativity and my ideas and thinking and
we would brainstorm as a group of
several different companies new product
ideas etc i loved his brilliance and i
guess over that we fell in love and uh
started secretly dating secretly dated
not so secret but yeah secretly dating
there was no um there was no sort of hr
department that would legally have
stopped that then i suppose they would
now i don't think it could happen i'm
not sure
but um yeah and he was he had been in
process for a green card for two years
and his green card came through
while we were dating
and he said i've got 90 days to go to
the states
and claim my green card if i don't go in
90 days i'd forfeit it and i said it's
like the golden ticket in willy wonka's
chocolate bar you can't you can't say no
you don't say no to the green card
get on a plane and go
and he said well
you know we were really you know serious
about each other and i said doesn't
matter if we're meant to be together we
will go and he said okay
all right
and we sort of broke up because he got
on a plane and flew to new york
and i had no idea i was gonna come here
i didn't i wasn't going to get a green
card
so off he went
and that was in may
of 82
and in the august of that year redken
who were based in los angeles wanted me
to come and do a training program here
because i was running the brand
and so i came on a two-week trip to la
and at that stage raymond had moved from
new york to chicago from chicago to la
so of course we'd kept in contact
writing letters and mail letters
and i knew he was in la and we arranged
to meet and then we knew this was it and
i
made a decision when i was on the flight
home back to south africa
i'm going to
be there it was um september when i flew
back i'm going to be there by christmas
i'm going to make a plan
and i did what was the plan
i don't know if it's completely legal
but i'll tell you
so what happened was while i was here
we wanted to explore how i would
get immigration how to get work permit
and so we went to see an immigration
attorney here in los angeles
and the easiest way was
to marry raymond who had a green card i
wasn't going to do that because i just i
i literally didn't get my divorce until
a few weeks after that so in south
africa so that wasn't going to happen
and i wasn't coming imminently i was
thinking you know in a year or two and i
just wanted to understand what it would
take how i could go about it
and so um i wasn't going to get married
for for
the the security of being able to
emigrate and i wasn't sure i wanted to
marry him anyway because we you know
we've been dating but i wasn't going to
make that mistake again and it was 10
years before we married in fact
but what happened was we went through
every single option of how you could get
a work permit i didn't fit any of them i
said well what if i had you know i'm a
trained skin therapist and he said it's
you know the training doesn't exist
the training exists here and i supply
i'm a trained teacher in skin therapy
which didn't exist here and actually
only 70 of the 50 states even had a
license to do skin care
but california was one of them
so what we what we put together was
we started a company raymond started a
company but we both together started it
we registered it in sacramento and it
cost 300 to start that company on the
understanding that i would
go back to south africa i would be made
a job offer
by that company in a management position
and i would transfer to
the states
the caveat was i had to i went to south
africa had to set up a company in south
africa because you had to have a company
in both places and that company had to
offer someone in management in that
other country a job
transfer and and it was not illegal it
was a slight loophole
which i have to say has been closed
because now i think you have to have 10
staff that already work for you in the
states and you have to have tax returns
for the last several years but that
wasn't the case then
and i transferred myself in on an
inter-company transfer visa
and you and raymond um end up starting a
company together
yeah national dermal international
dermal institute because i was on this
visa and i needed i would have to work
for myself
so to begin with i thought i'd work as
an independent contractor
and get a job in a salon so i went i did
the rounds in beverly hills uh of the
then that was the only place there were
skincare salons i could find in the
yellow pages which was the telephone
directory remember still no internet no
computers no google
and uh what i realized when i went on
interviews was that everyone they were
hiring had an accent from somewhere in
europe
and when i asked the people who were
interviewing me who were generally the
owners why are you why do you hire
people who were trained in europe why
they know americans they said the
training here is a few months and we're
used to several years the training's not
not good enough
for my clients for these clients
so yes i could have got a job in fact i
was offered jobs at each of the salons i
interviewed as an independent contractor
which is very common in our industry so
i'd be working for myself but in fact
working in their salon and but what
raymond and i were discussing was the
big opportunity oh my goodness what are
we talking about there is no there are
no skin therapist here and we're in los
angeles we're in california where i
thought everyone was going to be getting
a skin treatment every three minutes
because that was sort of the
myth of the states especially l.a
was not true at all it was makeup and
hair it wasn't skincare it wasn't spot
there was no such thing as a day spa
there was no such thing as a skin
treatment there was no such thing as
micro needling or any of the rest of it
that we think of now
that was an industry that had to be
established and so we started
a company called the international
dermal institute and the purpose of our
trade was a training program
i got my teaching qualification in south
africa as a skin care therapy teacher
and i done you know several years
experience in the industry wrote the
curriculum and our goal was to bridge
the gap in a training between what was
the california state board license which
was 600 hours about four months of
training and the two or three year
full-time training that was common in
europe and so in doing that
that would that would upskill the
professional skin therapist to be able
to start an industry
that we then would continue to train
so it was almost like training your own
industry and that's exactly how it
started and you know
we
knew this would be a huge opportunity
despite many people telling us we were
crazy because if it was such a good idea
why wasn't it already here yeah that's a
common thing to entrepreneurs if it's
such a good idea how come no one thought
of it before now and how did that go so
you launched that
that sort of sort of trade 83
the year i got here and how did it go
year one year one so really well and
i'll tell you why it went well because
in that year okay so i got here in
january 83 we're now in december 1983
when we incorporated the international
dermal institute
and we took that year to write the
curriculum do research do our homework
where we're going to draw these people
from and
raymond got a job selling equipment for
a skincare company that sold to salons
so now we were in contact with salons
and raymond wasn't selling any of this
equipment because it was too
sophisticated for the training that
existed here
so i started doing training for this
equipment
and so i spent that whole year training
salons how to use this equipment that
raymond was selling on a commission only
basis he wasn't getting a salary so in
order to eat and pay the rent on our one
bedroom apartment we needed him to start
selling some equipment and i needed to
be making money teaching and that's how
we put together our plan and that's how
we put together the idea of the
international domain institute so i'd
had a year of seeding students
and saying i'm going to be opening a
training center so rather than me just
demonstrating this machine to you i will
be able to teach you all the techniques
that i know
and that's going to be aromatherapy
manual lymph drainage it's going to be
waxing it's going to be reflexology
things that had never even been
introduced at that stage as well as of
course great skincare techniques
so we started the international dermal
institute classes were were filled
pretty much straight away
um we were charging then
75 dollars a day pretty quickly it went
up to a hundred dollars a day
people were driving to our one
classroom in marina del rey which was
walking distance from our apartment
because we only had one car and ray was
driving it
and um that's how we put it together and
then we built and we built a very
successful training program which is
still the number one advanced training
program in the industry we train over a
hundred thousand skin therapists every
year still
so we train around the world
but what i realized in the following
two years
there was no american-made professional
salon product
and that
was something that you didn't train and
get a certificate and leave
you would be purchasing on a repeat
basis so we knew because that was our
background was product as well
we knew that the big opportunity was
going to be a product
when you think about why the
training was so successful
and why you as an individual and your
husband succeeded in that what are the
like factors we think you know what
that's the thing that made us different
whether it's character or execution or
whatever it is yeah i know exactly what
it was
i'd love to tell you it was because i
wrote the most brilliant curriculum and
i am the best teacher neither of which
is true i wrote a good enough curriculum
and i'm a good enough teacher but what
we did
somewhat
inadvertently
is sort of accidentally on purpose if
you know what i mean community
we knew because i had been
that skin therapists are isolated we
work in rooms on our own and the busier
you become the more full your book is
with appointments you're in the
treatment room which is about an eight
by ten room
with your client
it's not and was not then performed out
in the public like hairdressing newer
hairdresser you can look across salon
and see five other people doing your job
as you do and you learn from them and
you're inspired by them and you have a
feeling of community in a salon and i
knew that because i'd been part of
full-service salons where they're
cutting hair and giving skin care
treatments and doing nails
and so we knew
that what was missing was this sense of
community all of our students that were
coming to the classes none of them
really knew each other they'd never met
other skin therapists there were only 2
000 in the whole state so it wasn't
surprising
so we doubled down
our whole mantra was make every excuse
think of every idea to bring
our people together guest speaker
evenings power breakfasts working
lunches summer picnics holiday party we
were doing everything any idea we saw
from what we saw in a coffee shop to
what we saw in a shoe repair shop we
were doing whatever we thought would
help us pull people together
for the ostensible reason of training in
skin care but in fact
was making them into a community
so much so that after about 18 months
two years
my students
said to me
you know what we're like family and i
said yes although we don't have the same
accents and they laughed and they said
no we're not family we're a tribe
it is human nature
that was the core of our success
and what i see now in the last two years
of of coved we've never needed it more
than now more than ever we need human
connection we are sick of our netflix
and our streaming and our everything we
want human connection we want to see
each other i want to see your smile i
want to see your face
i want to hug you i want to touch you
and guess what the industry that i have
spent my life in has never been more
relevant than now
because we're the cavalry
that's what we do as our work we
literally touch people not because
they're to look pretty pampering luxury
or indulgence because human connection
is the deepest form of unconditional
love
it's such a profound but seemingly
obvious piece of advice for how to
build an engaged customer base how to
build great company culture how to build
an audience if you're a social media
influencer but that yeah but you're
right it's it's right at the heart of
our sort of maslovian innate human needs
is to belong to a tribe yeah and what a
lot of people do as they become
successful they start to distance
themselves from it
they start to think
that was
i'm bigger than that or i'm better than
that
what
there's nothing better than being
connected to other people
in a loving kind empathetic way i talk a
lot you know in my book that you know
about empathy and the power of kindness
and i continue to learn that all the
time and and be accessible
i would always be accessible to my
students when we built our premises our
lunchroom was for students and staff i
would eat lunch in the lunchroom with
everyone else we all did because we
wanted i want to be with everybody else
i don't want to be on my own i want to
be with everyone else and i want
everyone else to know that they can be
with all of us we're all in this
together whether it's somebody when you
own a business and you think you're all
that well guess what the people that are
in your janitorial staff your
housekeepers they're making you look
good every day
because that's the image that people
have when they come in when i go to a
restaurant first thing i notice is how
clean is it how well cared for is it is
it loved
is this space loved and can i see that
it's loved are people taking pride in
this space because all of that is
non-communication that's non-verbal
communication and it all
matters
and we forget it because we start to
think it's us we're the things we're the
ones with the one it's nonsense complete
and utter nonsense and the minute you
start to feel that way you will fall
how would your team members that have
worked for you say for 10 years describe
you as a leader in terms of that that
balance you describe of empathy and
kindness and then also strength and
decisiveness well there's a lot of
people that have worked had have and had
worked for me for more than 10 years i'm
thinking now of laurie mcgregor who's
our director of khan senior director of
communications she's
in the studio right now and i could ask
her because she certainly worked with me
closely for many years i hope they would
describe me as fair
i hope they would describe me as kind
i hope they would describe me as
accessible
i hope they'd also say i was
collaborative because that's what i like
to think i am i believe i am what about
the weaknesses
lots
more than i could probably name my
strengths i'm impatient
i want things to be done now rather than
tomorrow
it can make me careless
i
see the flaws i see the good but i also
see the flaws if i walk into a salon and
somebody missed a piece of hair that
wasn't swept up i'm going to see it
first i just am i can't help it i have
that kind of vision
yes the product looks amazing yes the
lighting is great yes i love your
uniform and i love the storefront and
the great job you did with the windows
but why the hell is that hair in the
corner not swept up
i can't take my eyes off it but i'm also
not above going in the back finding the
dustpan and brush and brushing it up
myself because i will
will you say it like that yes yeah i'll
say it just like that
you know when you say it like that yeah
about the hair being on the floor yeah
that it will make people feel a certain
way i'm the same yeah so why do you say
it like that
well i would i probably the likelihood
would be i would start that conversation
by saying to the person i'm sorry
do you have a dustband and brush in the
kitchen in the staff room
and they'll say uh yeah why i say just
just show me what it is you have to do
it
and i would come out with a dustband
brush and i would sweep it up and then
i'd say because the only thing i could
look at when i came in here was that
hair in the corner
now
let's talk about
all the great things you do but let's
never forget
but that's important it might be some
version of that but i certainly wouldn't
say i wouldn't walk in and go i'm sorry
excuse me before we do anything i can't
see a thing
that hair in the corner
someone sweep it up i wouldn't do that
i'm not a diva but i am strong and i
know what makes a business successful
and i can't allow a business to not
hear what my thought is if i think it
will make them more successful and i
know it will it's not a matter of taste
or style
that's a matter of hygiene
so then i'm fierce
and that attention to detail tell me how
important it is in your view now you've
been in business for so long
how important is because some people say
oh that's petty okay
it's huge it's everything
the devil
and god are in the details here's the
deal
there is no shortage of a good idea
lots of people have great ideas every
day the difference most people can't
execute
and if they can execute they don't
execute well and if they execute well
they can't maintain it how do you stay
relevant and growing in an industry like
my industry cosmetics makeup skin care
hair fashion how do you stay relevant
for almost 40 years and stay the leader
if you're not paying attention to detail
you'll peak and you'll drop in a quick
minute you're going to be a party that
happened overnight you're not going to
be a relationship that lasts a lifetime
two different things both can be fun but
one is a long game that you're playing
and one is a short-term fix that you
want
and that's very different it's like
dating and a marriage or dating in a
long relationship
you're playing a long game and for me
business was always about playing the
long game we didn't build dermalogica to
flip it and sell it we could have done
that after three or four years and if it
wasn't going well we probably would have
done but we were self-funded on fourteen
thousand dollars highly profitable
and took it all the way through to
acquisition in 2015 by unilever
and i'm still involved with dermalogica
i still function my title is chief
visionary and when
things are going wrong or i think you're
making the wrong turn i'm gonna tell you
you don't have to listen to me you don't
have to agree with me but i'm going to i
have to know
that i said it because the details are
really important and most people miss
them or start to think they're petty
the other thing you mentioned which i
found fascinating is you added to your
list of weaknesses in patients yeah
but
you are well aware of the strengths of
impatience of course that's the thing
whatever is your weakness
flip it it's like a coin the other side
is your strength
now i know that sounds
like complete opposite right but i'm
impatient so as a weakness especially
when i'm tired i'm not making tiredness
an excuse but especially when i'm tired
it can make you angry
it can make you short-tempered
it can make you
um
rude
amen and so you have to take a moment
and get yourself in check because
impatience can also lead to a fast pace
to a quick idea to a rapid execution to
a sense of urgency to a sense of
excitement to a sense of enthusiasm to a
definite sense of leadership in in the
team so that very quality is your
strength and is your weakness and you
have to be able to
i always i say in the book you have to
have a truth teller now hopefully your
truth teller is yourself so that you can
say that wasn't my best self or that was
not that was
my strength at its weakest moment
and if you don't if you're not good at
being truthful or honest with yourself
you better have somebody around you that
is
because you'll have a lot of you know
ass kisses around you especially when
you're successful not when you start
but especially when you're successful
and you have to know it's not not
necessarily because they're insincere
but they're not going to be your truth
tellers so that's lovely to have and
it's lovely maybe for your ego or
whatever it is for inviting to parties
but you have to have some truth tellers
have you got truth tellers around you
yes that will tell you when you're
you're out of line or that you've been
rude
my number one truth teller is raymond
yeah he will tell me he has no filter he
has no ability to edit
he's about the kindest and most generous
person i've ever known he's certainly
the smartest person but he has
absolutely no edit button and i will say
to him sometimes roman i cannot believe
he just said that he said but it's true
it's true
and he's right okay so that's raymond
and then i have people in my tight team
natalie byrne who works with me on
strategy for our non-profit she will
call me and has many times sometimes
late at night and say jane i can't stop
thinking about this i think what you
said today was off base or off the mark
or whatever it is and we talk about it
and she's
almost 100 right and that's i tell her
natalie
i love you because you tell me the truth
don't ever i don't want to hurt your
feelings i said natalie please you will
not hurt my feelings
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete if
you haven't tried the heel protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like
on the point of impatience one of the
things i read that i really resonated
with a lot and it's in fact something
that barack obama had said when i spoke
at conference with him in brazil
is this idea of making decisions yes
before you're at 100
and people really struggle with this but
some people it's the most liberating
thing they can hear and i've had a guest
come on this podcast that said when you
said that that changed my life i read
you you said the exact same thing you
said you know get to 70 yeah that's my
number i don't even know if that's the
real number but it just feels right yeah
70 sounds right if you've got 70
of the information
that you will need to make a decision
make it
don't you will not get 100 because
by the time you even think you're at 100
the situation's changed it needs a
decision now
leadership requires decisiveness
and you need to make a decision
immediately
whether it's in a war-torn country
or whether it is in a strife-driven life
i mean you need to make the decision
so i would say to people who i would
hire
let me give you the lowdown of how this
works because most people want to know
how do i become successful in this
company let's say or words to that
effect
and my answer is always you will get 10
points
for making the right decision
you will get no points for making the
wrong decision
but you will get minus 10 points
if you don't make a decision
you can't be in a meeting and not speak
up
because then you're an audience we want
an audience you can get a chair and sit
over there and listen if you want to but
you must have an opinion and you must
state it
that's what you're here for that's why
we want you
decisiveness is critical because in
order to make that decision i have to
hear all the opinions doesn't mean i'm
going to
it's going to persuade me differently
although it might
but ultimately the buck stops with the
person who's going to have to make that
ultimate decision and you must make it
one of the other quotes which i found
really
interesting and inspiring was that your
aim when you started dermalogica was to
piss off the 80 and to please the 20
that's that's a quote taken from your
book skin in the game yeah raymond
that's raymond's phrase in fact what
happened was we were
i won't use the word beauty and and so
i was bemoaning the fact that you know
people
didn't agree with that you know i used
to get people saying this you know
you're running down our industry your
disgrace to our industry because i
wouldn't say i was a beauty therapist
and or a beautician and i mean this
these are all great names i'm happy for
you to call yourself anything you want
to just doesn't apply to me i don't
apply that to my work so i was having
this sort of like rant with raymond and
he said but we can't be afraid that some
people won't like what we say we have to
say it we actually ran out an add-on
based on that conversation which was mel
who worked front desk for us holding a
sign
saying um we're not pretty
and at the bottom we just put the
company logo
and because
and ray said we understand something
this was a team of us marketing we have
to be prepared to piss off 80
or will never turn on 20
will be middle of the road mediocre
average palatable
but not definable
that's a product that's not a brand a
brand has a voice a brand has a
personality a brand triggers emotional
responses
and so that became our kind of watch
word in marketing we need to piss off 80
and turn on 20 we don't need everyone to
like us and if we're not being
decisive and if we're not being truthful
and if we're not being um slightly
disruptive um we're not being true to
ourselves
and if we're not doing any of that then
everyone's going to like us but not a
lot no one's going to hate us but not a
lot and we can't walk that middle ground
so it was a couple of years into your
training company
that you launched dermalogica yeah so
1983
we started the international dermal
institute and we launched dermalogica in
january of 1986.
and the resistance you faced talk to me
about the resistance and the challenges
you faced in trying to launch that
company because i know there were plenty
well at that time
everything was sort of the industry was
segmented into cosmetics
that included skin care hair care makeup
whatever you can think of artifice
decoration that's why i don't ever put
skin care in the cosmetic industry which
is an amazing industry and i love it
uh but it's not my industry my industry
is skincare it's very specific and it's
different and it's closely related to
nutrition healthcare
and um
and and self
self-care
so and human connection
so therefore
when we started we wanted to form this
hybrid between a cosmetic
and a pharmaceutical
there was nothing in the middle of those
two things then 1986 but remember this
is conversations happening in 85 because
we launched in 86.
so we wanted to put together this thing
between the two so what did that mean it
had to look like a pharmaceutical but
perform like
a cosmetic had to be cosmetically
elegant but it couldn't look
luxury couldn't be a pink jar with a
gold lid
so all of that idea of branding
influenced what our voice was going to
be
the name derma means skin logica means
sensible sense
simple serious and unique
that was kind of our mantra
so we we took a lot of pushback for that
we were told our packaging is ugly
why don't you use jars jars are you know
the industry standard and they're
disgusting and you because they
contaminate with bacteria not just from
your hands but also because we tend to
use our products in bathrooms now not at
dressing tables in your dressing room
and in a bathroom e coli bacteria is
airborne there's more bacteria in your
bathroom than anywhere else so you
really don't want that in a jar of cream
it's like people have a bar of soap in
their shower and they take that bar and
somebody uses the bar and washes their
bits and pieces and the next person gets
in and washes their face it's disgusting
so
we were talking about all of this and we
were getting pushed back
and we just we just weathered it and uh
i spoke at a big conference for the
industry in glasgow a world conference
in 1987
and i was speaking about this kind of
thing and after i had 25 minutes
assigned to me for my presentation
and after i think it was about nine
minutes the organizers came up and
switched the mic off
and asked me to leave the stage
because they said what i was talking
about was
counterpoint to
kind of anarchy in the industry and what
i was talking about was that
salons should not be gender specific
that we shouldn't have male salons and
female sons in fact there is no
gender
binary
and we should sell product in our salons
because clients need to have product to
take home and maintain the results they
just paid us for in the treatment room
and apparently me suggesting
that there is no binary in a target
market for our work skin care
and
skin care is
not a luxury it should be a necessity
for everyone and we should retell
products
was deemed to be an anarchy in the
industry
now it pissed off probably 80 of the
people i guess in that room i don't know
but
the 20
of skin therapists who heard that
message
crowded
our stand there at the trade show that
was part of that conference
and applauded when i got back to our
booth there were a crowd of skin
therapists applauding
because they were waiting
to have a business a profession an
industry to be proud of and it was not a
hobby or something i did for pin money
or something i did on the side was
something that you know it's my little
thing i love skin i don't make any money
at it they said we need a career we need
a profession we need an industry and a
voice that will speak for us because we
love this work and we want it to be
profitable otherwise how do we pay the
rent
and so that was my rallying call the 20
were always my tribe
i think that's it's so unbelievably
important especially as it relates to
marketing and branding to
to have a perspective to stand for
something or else you fall into this
category of like
indifference and people trying to please
everyone and pleasing no one as you say
yeah i you know the business did
phenomenally well as well so dermalogica
you made a million dollars roughly in
your first year yeah eventually that
business gets acquired by unilever your
other company still to this day
is going incredibly strong as you say
it's the the number one in the world in
its category i think i read that you had
1 400 employees yeah or something like
that yeah staggering yeah
and that business generates hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
how hard did you have to work
how many hours were you working in those
early dermalogica days
oh it's a blur
24 24 wow so no seriously um
the minute we woke up
seven o'clock earlier if it was
something you know we were fretting
about or a trade show that we had to
pack up and go
uh all the way through till we fell
asleep
i i don't there is no work-life balance
it's all your big messy life
you know people who say how do you
balance your life and your work i know
that they hate one of those two parts in
their own life
i've never wanted to my it's not that my
life is my work or my work is my life
it's all part of my life
and i want all of it so i try and make
it happen i can't do it all at the same
time i waited till i was 36 to have my
first child i really thank god that i
was able to have two children and kind
of snuck in
what i feel under the under the rope and
a lot of people that that doesn't happen
for them i feel really grateful for that
but the reason one of the reasons we put
off having children was we were just
working so hard and traveling
it was word of mouth where there was no
social media there were no influences
the influences were our skin therapists
and if word of mouth meant you had to
find someone and tell them so we were
working every trade show i was flying to
new york where all the magazines were
being published and with my box of
products when i was literally sitting in
the lobby of conde nast hoping that any
one of the editors from any one of their
magazines you know please god it might
be vogue will come downstairs and i can
grab them in the lobby before they get
out the door or see them as they get in
the elevator that was before they had
secure elevators so you could get into
the elevator with someone and give them
up literally an elevator pitch before
they got to the 14th floor where their
magazine was
and i
and i was lonely and i was scared and i
would go to vogue and and you know all
the magazines or hearst publishing and
and just sit there with my little box of
products saying what am i doing i was
just like pull it together because
you've got to keep watching those doors
when those elevator doors open if it's
someone you've got to go over and say
one minute and press that sample of skin
prep scrub into their hands
and
and it worked
what's the cost of that though that
working
you know seven days a week tremendous
hours what is the cost i think the
greatest cost is friendships
i had friends who really were annoyed
that we were just never available me as
a person and i was a couple because we
came as a couple really so
um we were never available for sunday
brunch we couldn't go out on a saturday
night because i was teaching on a sunday
i taught every sunday
we were running errands on a saturday we
were doing laundry every night after the
class and we lost a lot of friends that
i look back and i'm sorry that we lost
them because i liked them and i thought
that our friendship might have a shot at
withstanding it
but
the friends who are still our friends
understood it and they talk about it now
say oh my god just remember when
and we say yes you know i would i would
invite everyone for dinner but we were
having indian takeout because i i
couldn't cook i mean no i can cook but i
didn't have time to have enough time to
do the shopping there was no instacart
we kept
our closest friends and our dearest
friends are still with us but i think
friendship is the thing the thing you
lose did you have to because i'm
thinking once upon a time i i am i was
in a relationship with someone i worked
with did you have to
make
time like you know romance time date
night date night all that stuff did you
have you ever done anything never i've
never had a date night really no i don't
know how does that work so you say we're
going on a date on thursday yeah so then
we go on a date so we're going out to
dinner maybe whatever you're doing
you're walking on the beach you're
having alone time with that person and
do you not talk about anything other
than your relationship
i don't know you talk about
the food on the menu and i don't know
the music or you know and then there's
sort of pressure that you're going to
have sex or whatever is that
i'm just wondering i've never done a
date night because
i can't even i know what raymond would
say because we've talked about it i've
said tim do you want to go on like if
you ever heard about this date night
this is like years ago and you go what's
that and i said you know when you get
together with your partner and you talk
about things that you just talk about
yourselves i guess or like your
relationship the things that are
important important
um what do you think about that
i just looked at me he said don't we do
that every night and the answer is
yes i mean for our relationship i'm not
for one second saying you shouldn't have
a date night we know that barack obama
and michelle obama used to famously have
their date nights i'm just not sure that
ray and i would be able to keep a
straight face on it we talk about
everything all the time if we're upset
with each other we say i'm really upset
with what you said to me yesterday i
just felt like you weren't listening to
me
or
um
we went to a dinner party and i kept
trying to catch you right at the dinner
table because i was sat next to this
ridiculous crazy person who was like
saying the biggest conspiracy theories
in the world to me and you wouldn't look
at me you've got to remember we've got
look at each other so i can catch your
eye for us it's just one big messy
relationship and um
we never took our personal arguments to
work
uh we did used to bring work
conversations home we called them fierce
conversations
but ray and i are the kind of couple
that we will
we call it you know you put the
mattresses against the wall you you stay
in the room mattresses against the wall
until you have figured it out and you
are not leaving this room until we do
and we will reach we will reach a point
of
agreement and we will
so you don't let that resentment sort of
foster no try not to sometimes it's
inevitable it still bugs me some things
that raymond does i know that i annoy
the hell out of him sometimes but
nothing that's important enough to
not be playing a long game for life with
this person
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
you made a comment earlier on about
therapy
and i thought it was i wasn't sure if it
was flippant or serious but uh have you
ever been to therapy
and what what for
i had not seen a therapist although i
now realize i really should have i'm
quite positive about that until um
about five years ago
and what happened five years ago
it was pretty soon after we'd sold the
company which was momentous but i felt
like i was dealing with it fine
raymond lost his father
passed away
we
had a house in santa barbara that we
were that was our forever house we we
went up to santa barbara we raised our
kids every summer up there it's a beach
community about
80 miles north of los angeles that's our
go-to place where we feel safe we feel
protected if we ever had a
a staff event that we wanted to have a
small group and discuss stuff we would
do it in santa barbara we had meetings
there we it was just like our
place and we had this great house like a
farmhouse and and i loved the garden and
i plot replanted the garden and
i
i loved the house and in january of 2018
santa barbara had massive
fire the thomas fire
and soon after there was flash flooding
and giant mudslide from the mountains
above
and our house was destroyed
and if we had been in it which we were
not and the only reason we were not is
this mudslide happened the
late
hours of january 8th early morning
january 9th
and lucy our youngest child's birthday
is january 8th and we came back to la to
celebrate it with her friends here if
we'd been in our house in santa barbara
we wouldn't have made it out a huge
massive boulder came straight through
the master bedroom which was on the
ground floor
and we would have we would have been
killed
that was the tipping point for me
and to begin with i felt like i just
wasn't coming to terms with the fact
that we'd lost the house and raymond was
becoming really
worried about me and he kept saying jane
i cannot believe you're attaching
this much to a
to a place to a house to a possession to
our stuff it's stuff
like we're safe
and for some reason i just couldn't put
it down i couldn't get through it i was
carrying it with me like a
weight
and i wasn't sleeping and i started not
sleeping and i went for 41 nights with
less than 44 hours sleep a night
i clocked it
and i went to see my doctor who said i i
think you need to we need to book you
into the
sleep clinic at ucla the university of
california los angeles and there was a
three-month wait list
so i decided i was going to go talk to
my doctor about sleeping tablets
and i went and he recommended ambien
and i'd never take an ambien
and i and i really didn't know if i
wanted to start taking that
and he casually said
well maybe you know psychologically
there's a reason you're not sleeping so
i decided i'd go see a psychiatrist who
i knew
our youngest child had an eating
disorder and had seen this person this
doctor and i went to her and i said i'm
not sleeping and she said let me do some
cognitive testing which she did and then
she said okay you are did you drive here
and i said yeah and she said you
shouldn't drive home
you cognitively
should not you should not be driving
we've got to get you sleeping
and through trial and error she tried
every sleeping tablet on the market and
i nothing helped me 10 milligrams of
milligram didn't help
i'd wake up after three hours
and ultimately she said jane you don't
have an insomnia problem
you have an anxiety problem
and i had to dig in and deal with it
and of course
as i dug into losing the house it wasn't
about the house the house was
representative of every loss i've ever
had in my life going all the way back
to when i was two and three quarters
years old and lost my father had to go
all the way back and dig in
and unpack it and realize
why
not who i am but why i am who i am
had that not happened had i not been
able to unpack all of that
and then realize how much i had in that
suitcase
and which pieces it was okay to
put in a cupboard and
close it know it's there but not have to
wear it every day and which were the
bits i needed to wear every day because
it was so much part of who i am i i know
i couldn't have written the book and i
don't know that i would be in the place
i am today
is it the awareness of what's going on
in the suitcase that that is the
liberating thing or is there also like
tools and techniques and strategies of
dealing with triggers or moments that i
think it's both but for me what has been
successful
is having the right questions asked
and you're excellent at this so you know
this
how did that make you feel or what were
you thinking then or
what did you do immediately after that
and not having that person tell me
therefore what happened
but allowing me to think
oh that's that's interesting i um
i had a bath
or whatever it might be you know
and then slowly over the next sometimes
it's a few days sometimes it's a few
months sometimes a couple of years you
start to realize i'm seeing a pattern
here there's a pattern here that i'm
recognizing in myself
and then
for me
um
the tools i get given tools to try
encouraged to try try thinking about it
this way
one thing when i would talk about my
childhood for example and i was ashamed
that i didn't have a father and i and i
felt ashamed when my mother started to
develop alzheimer's and and was still
socially active but clearly not herself
i've reframed that as how proud i am of
my parents
and i am
and i'm proud
of my mum's fortitude and i'm proud of
her determination and i can talk with
pride about my mother and father and not
feel
anything else not feel any other emotion
other than of course love
and i'm really grateful for that
and uh
i think that a lot of people
not laugh at therapy but knock it
and i think it's because it's probably
the single most terrifying thing you
ever do
is really look deep
at
your choices and actions and behaviors
and it's much
kinder to oneself to just keep it packed
up we can keep that locked away we don't
need to discuss it don't look at that
stop talking about that you don't need
to go about that that's over that's in
the past why do you keep talking about
that don't you don't need to you're okay
now oh best not to bother best not to
leave well alone i've heard all that my
whole life i mean that i grew up under
that not just from my family but from
people
and
i realized now
no i think that's the only way you
really find who you are
and maybe you can do it with best
friends helping you maybe you can do it
as a client of a skincare therapist who
listens to everything you tell them
and if you do that's great but however
it works for you find the way that helps
you examine
because a life unexamined is a life not
lived
so it's so interesting you know i sit
here with lots of guests on this podcast
and many of them have taken the
taken the leap or made the decision at
some point to go to therapy and to start
kind of unpacking things that have
happened to them in their life and yet i
still
and they speak to the profound impact
positive impact it's had on their life
and yet i still as i sit here today
definitely feel a stigma myself about
going yeah it's okay you're twenty-eight
i'm twenty-nine yeah twenty-nine okay so
definitely people told me many people i
was in relationships told me in my
twenties that you know you should see
someone or you know and i it would to me
there was a stigma there was nothing
wrong with me and i had good friends
that i could talk to and i had sisters i
could tell
but none of them are completely as
objective as we think they might be and
of course it's not
completely confidential
and i'm now 63 i'm going to be 64 next
saturday
and i think
there's a point where we start to
be ready
and if not not
and you'll know when it is
because your body will tell you it won't
be your mind it won't be the stigma
it'll be something i thought i had
insomnia
i could have just probably started
swallowing ambien and thinking oh well
this doesn't work either i guess i'm
just getting older and i don't sleep but
you see i wasn't able to function
without sleeping
so my body literally
took me to a place where i had to ask
for help and it took all those years
and so
it's okay that there's a stigma it's
okay you don't want to do it then don't
do it it's not maybe it's not right for
you now probably not very much to unpack
even though you feel like there's a lot
and maybe you haven't seen the pattern
repeat itself enough for you to think
oh it's not that person or that person
this is actually my pattern
and so you know i just think all of us
should find our way however we can
the symptoms the symptoms culminated um
well your
the unpacked suitcase culminated in this
insomnia later in your life yeah but now
in hindsight now that you've been and
you've spoken about it and you've
unpacked these things and understood
them better
can you identify other symptoms that
were present at other phases in your
life or was it just at that point when
you got insomnia that you thought well i
need to
was there
i
used to pride myself that i left a
relationship before anyone left me
right and
i think because of that fear of being
the one left
alone
i would self-sabotage
relationships whether they be
friendships or whether they be personal
intimate
relationships and that might work very
well until
you have children
and that changes everything
for me
well because you
are
forced to i tell a story in in my book
about my youngest child lucy
before cell phones we had established a
routine of we all had breakfast together
ray and i always ate breakfast together
even if it was a banana and a cup of tea
stood in the kitchen
and then as we had children we would
literally take 10 minutes to just sit
around the table and have a piece of
toast a bowl of cereal whatever
and just say you know have a great day
and
you know you didn't have to have any
kind of profound conversation just be
present
and um with cell phones i started to get
you know emails and texts coming in from
our markets in europe that were already
four o'clock in the afternoon at eight
o'clock in the morning you know that
you're nodding now obviously because you
do so we had a 24-hour business
and so i started to get into the habit
of just checking just quickly just
checking my emails and texts before i
sat down to breakfast
and then i would walk lucy to the bus
stop for school and then it got to where
i would check them before i sat down for
breakfast so that i knew what was on my
plate and then i'd walk at a school and
then it got to i would check them and
then maybe i couldn't sit down for
breakfast because i had to just quickly
answer this text you know how that goes
it's a slippery slope but i'm so busy
and i'm successful and i'm working i'm
not fooling around i'm not like you know
reading the the comics or anything at
the back of the paper i'm working i mean
i'm answering as a crisis there's a
crisis in new zealand
so i was on my phone and and earlier i
come down at like 6 30 and i was busy
scrolling and i had to quickly answer
there was a catastrophe it was a bit of
a disaster happening in the uk and i had
to answer them they needed an answer now
because it was the end of the day there
and lucy came downstairs and she said
morning mom and i said and i didn't say
i just kind of like nodded and
said waved at her like hi hi she sat
down and i was busy texting texting
looking at something and she said and
then from the chair she got up from the
table and she said mom and i said lucy
just one minute hang on
mom and i said lucy just one minute
please
and carry on and she said mum i just and
i said lucy please can you not see i'm
busy i've got a whole thing happening in
the uk and i have to get back to them
and i suddenly saw her eyes well up and
i said lucy for goodness sake what is
wrong
and she said
i wanted to give you a hug you look so
cross
and it was
i was just stood there with this stupid
bloody phone in my hand and my child in
front of me
looking scared of me
and i just put down the phone i got on
my knees i gave her a big hug and said
lucy i'm so sorry
and she started crying then i started
crying i said lucy i'm so sorry there is
nothing more important than you and
being here right now
i got distracted by business it's not
acceptable i promise you it will never
happen again
and i made a rule it never did
it doesn't make me any more perfect a
parent
my mum was very busy she worked a lot
it's not about that
it's about knowing when the moment it's
not a long a moment
is important to pay attention
and that day at least for that person my
child when someone says mum i'm
listening
how do you make sure that despite the
crisis that might emerge at any given
moment in any day and also just the
general gravitational pull that business
has because of the allure allure that
you can be more successful or make more
money how do you make
sure that you are allocating your time
against your true priorities like
spending time with your children or like
friendships or like your husband because
we both know that we could just spend
all of our time just doing business yeah
so how do you
i really think about
is this a true
emergency
or is it a rush of adrenaline because
being able to solve this or do something
about this is making me feel
relevant
important
special
needed
bigger
and if it's for any of those reasons it
can wait
your ego can wait
or is this moment not as much about me
but about the people i love or
their need to show me love
it's it's not easy because we're
impatient so we get caught up in that
rush and that's the thing that made us
successful that's the thing that drives
us that's the thing that without that we
wouldn't be us
and yet
take a breath and just say okay wait a
minute does this have to be done
right now while i've got this other
person my child my husband my partner my
mother my wife fill in the blank
or could it wait
four minutes
could it wait an hour
could it wait till tonight
could it wait till next week
does it actually have to be answered
and trust me if it is a tick-tock
or a social media thing or anything like
that i will tell you the answer now
you know it
it does not have to be answered right
away i don't care if you've got 2
million followers 22 million 120 it
doesn't have to be answered right away
unless literally it is an emergency so
just take a beat take a minute and
decide
who needs this time the most and
sometimes it's not another person it's
you
sometimes you need that minute the most
i need this minute for me now
so take a break
and go and have that time for yourself
because you need that as well
i heard one of the things you said as
advice to entrepreneurs is to first and
foremost make sure you are one
oh yeah make sure you are listen not
everyone's an entrepreneur it sounds
like the cool thing to be right the sexy
thing is to be an entrepreneur some
people are not cut out to be
entrepreneurs to be an entrepreneur it's
not just that you are a risk taker right
i hate hearing it's just so tired cliche
to say you know entrepreneurs are great
risk takers entrepreneurs are not
frightened of being scared
let's say that it's not that we're not
scared we are but we'll
deal with it courage bravery is not the
absence of fear it's the presence of
fear and still being able to function
so that you have to have you always have
to be decisive you have to be able to
make a decision you have to um
have 70 and make a call not everyone has
that and then you don't have to
you can also have a bit of that and be
an intrapreneur so you think
entrepreneurially within someone else's
company which is fine that's like
playing in vegas without using your own
chips
but it's not the rush of using your own
chips you know the entrepreneur we're
using our own chips and it's
once you get it's easy to risk a few
chips when you haven't got many on the
table when the chips start stacking up
and you want to put everything on red 22
well that's going to be a huge gamble so
it's that kind of energy it's very
different so you've got entrepreneurs
you have entrepreneurs you also have i
think two kinds of entrepreneurs you've
got entrepreneurs that are serial
entrepreneurs they flip it then they
build it and flip it build it and flip
it and they they're very good at
starting things but they can't follow
they don't want to follow through and
grow it
and then you get a long long player like
like me and raymond where you build one
company or two and you grow it
into an acquisition and that defines
your entrepreneurship both are great
either are fine
you have to find what your path is and
you find that by finding what your
purpose is and what's your fastest route
to get there
and for us it was entrepreneurship but
it's not for everybody and neither
should it be and
that's the that's the magic find find
your path
i know you weren't intent on selling
dermalogica especially in the early
years but you ultimately did yes
two questions yeah question one is the
week after you sell dermalogica how did
you feel about it and the second thing
is why why did you choose to sell the
company
euphoric
really yes and i'll tell you why because
we knew exactly why we were selling um
i don't know it ever feels that way if
you resell you sell regretfully or
because of a some other reason but the
reason we sold was
we felt strongly we had taken
dermalogica
to as far as we could run it
we were
not that there were other people that
were so much more clever than us out
there i did think that in the early days
there must be someone who knows all
these answers but then you realize
pretty quickly people don't no one has
the answers no one knows your business
better than you do so it wasn't that so
much that if we thought of it as a relay
race
raymond and i ran the first leg
but you're running so fast and so hard
at your fullest capacity you can't
possibly run the second third and fourth
legs
so you have to pass that baton into a
different kind of runner who the second
leg is a different kind of runner as is
the third leg and guess what the fourth
leg
is the one that's going to take it home
so
we felt very strongly about that we had
rule we didn't need we didn't want to go
to an ipo
because we don't play well in the
sandbox with other people could we have
promoted someone from within and like
stayed on as benevolent you know owners
no i mean we were aging out we were
definitely you know we realized our
relevancy
was going to be was going to wane what
we knew and what we knew how to do
life was changing the world was changing
it was time we knew you've got to know
when to leave the party
i don't know about you but i'm very good
at knowing when to leave
yeah and raymond is excellent at knowing
when i should leave the party too and so
he said this is the time the time is
we've got to pass the baton and it's
going to be an acquisition and then in
the book skin in the game i tell the
story of the acquisition because the
likely suspects of who would acquire us
people in the cosmetic industry in
prestige
sure they were at the table at the
beginning but at the end of the day what
guided us was a shared value system and
the shared value system was unilever
and we're still with them and
we appointed our first ceo
when we sold he's still our ceo he's
terrific the team stayed on board ray
and i have stayed involved
the company continues going strength to
strength they're in double-digit growth
so we know we chose the right partner so
we felt euphoric about it
and now i feel gratified that we did the
right thing promise you i don't miss it
a bit and i'm incredibly proud of what
we did
i guess that's when you know it's the
right time yeah you built wealth over
many many years from two different
businesses so this even the acquisition
of unilever i'm guessing wasn't a
life changing in terms of the
fundamentals of your life moment no
right so when you think about those two
wonderful daughters you have and leaving
them that that money
yeah you know what question i'm going to
say
ask me because you're you know much of
your tenacity and your hunger has come
from not having it i remember hearing
the stories of you like looking down the
back of the sofas for coins when you're
younger all these things that you did
are you scared that your kids won't have
that same tenacity and hunger if you
leave them your your wealth
yes absolutely and let me tell you
something they're 23 and 28
we better have done a good enough job by
now because
you're not changing i don't know that
you can change someone at 23 or 20. you
couldn't change me at 23 or 28. we we um
we raised them in the house that we
bought way before the acquisition we
bought it 18 years before the
acquisition
we live in a nice neighborhood we don't
live in a gated community i don't live
in a mansion i'd never had living help
or anything like that i didn't want it
it's not who i am it's not my value
system it's not raymond's we raise them
in as normal a childhood as anyone has i
never i mean who had a normal childhood
i think they have a very strong value
system they're aware that they are
incredibly
uh fortunate they also know
that a sense of purpose means how does
it benefit other people
and that wealth is a burden if you don't
figure out how it can benefit others and
give you some sense of
gratitude at having it
so
yes of course we've done estate planning
and of course
we don't want to see our children not
taken care of and
they will also
understand how they're going to take
care of other people people they know
and also people that they don't know and
will never meet because that's part of
it if you are given this kind of
opportunity you have a responsibility
or as i like to call it another equal
and opposite opportunity
to do something with it
and i think if you don't recognize that
pretty quickly
it becomes a burden and can lead to
incredible unhappiness
and uh i really hope that ray and i have
done the right things to make sure that
doesn't happen i feel pretty good so far
i have a high degree of confidence that
you have by how you've delivered that
because it seems to be very well thought
through
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest writes
a question for the next guest
and i don't get to see it until i open
this book so on a scale of one to ten of
self-love how much do you accept
yourself have positive thoughts about
yourself have healed your wounds and
fully love who you are authentically
i one being you don't love yourself at
all and ten being you love yourself
authentically
i love myself authentically 10
and it's taken me
help and support and trust and faith to
get there but i honestly do
with my flaws
it's not that i think i'm perfect it's
that i am always learning and i'm open
to being better
yes
it's a beautiful sense of sort of
self-empathy to that yeah yeah i'm kind
to myself
well thank you so much jane honestly the
i learned so much just from researching
your life and your book the the sort of
human vulnerable honest nature whilst
also this constant undertone of real
actionable advice is what makes it so
important i think that's the best use of
words thank you thanks
as you might know my energy are a
sponsor of this podcast and they offer
countless ways to make your life a
little bit more sustainable and make
that transition from where you are now
to a sustainable life ten times easier
their products are all about energy
independence allowing you to create a
greener home through their
cost-effective and super user-friendly
products and one of my favorite products
right now is the zappy it's a smart ev
charger which simply allows you to
charge your electric vehicle from solar
or wind power so if you would like to
find out more about my energy then head
to myenergy.com and if you've tried the
zappy let me know how you got on with it
in the comments section below
[Music]
you